what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay because I've kind of reworked my
schedule so that Monday Wednesday and
Friday are our DC rebirth days which is
to say those are the days we're gonna
upload DC rebirth videos I was going
through the playlist which you'll find
down in the description and one of the
things I noticed is that we haven't done
a lot of stuff with DC rebirth like
we've covered a lot of the really really
good stories but in terms of going
through and creating this kind of
comprehensive cohesive playlist of
basically everything in rebirth there's
a lot that we haven't done there are
even some of the rebirth one-shot
stories that we haven't done like
Superman Justice League so we're gonna
do on Monday Wednesday and Fridays we're
gonna kind of like double up on DC
Weaver stuff one of the videos will be
the old you know older like Wendy's who
were first started basically playing
catch-up and the other ones will be the
modern stories the stories that are
going on right now and rebirth so that
way we kind of get the best of both
worlds but this story a lonely place of
living through this story's insane man
like this the story is so good today is
such an amazing writer when it comes to
Batman it's absolutely crazy but this
story serves a couple purposes the first
thing that I want you guys to bear in
mind is this story takes place at least
this first little bit takes place before
the Oz effect and then it takes place
during the Oz effect so it's actually
kind of cool you sort of get these two
things going on at the same time the
other thing is that of course this does
take place before a Dark Knight's metal
which is one of the reasons why we're
gonna see Bruce Wayne following that
actually I think it takes place after
Dark Knights metal because we have Tim
Drake who basically returns this do you
see one of those stories where like Dark
Knights metal takes place either like
right at the time the story starts or
like right you know right before the
story starts but we haven't seen Tim
Drake in Dark Knights metal so we could
just kind of just go by virtue of the
evidence at hand then this takes place
you know after the events of Dark
Knights metal which is a bit of a
spoiler to a degree is you know again
metal is kind of weird and as you know
in terms of its placement and so on and
so forth but regardless this basically
sees the return of Tim Drake but the
other role this story plays is this
actually a prelude to the super Sons of
tomorrow which is an amazing story going
on right now so classic DC characters
are coming back in ways I didn't think
they would and it's actually pretty
solid now remember Tim Drake had
quote-unquote died during the first
story arc of Detective Comics rise of
the Batman and the whole idea was that
there was basically the father of Kate
Cain that woman who had shown up at the
you know The Belfry bases in the
location of where the bat family was
operating out of outside of the bat cave
and the overall goal of the colony that
organization near that was led by that
woman's father was to basically invade
the bat cave invaded you know all the
bat fortresses take all the technology
and effectively militarized the
man concept the problem with this is of
course while they were defeated Tim
Drake had kind of made this you know
ultimate sacrifice more or less we're
always believed that he had died the
problem was that he was whisked away by
mr. Oz and he been held there ever since
and so up to this point which is to say
the time this story's being written
right now and maybe even the story
beforehand Bruce Wayne largely thought
that Tim Drake was dead
almost the entire bat family thought
that Tim Drake was dead now because of
the fact that DC rebirth is the entry
point for a lot of people when it comes
to DC Comics Tim Drake's origin is kind
of retold here it really comes as a
series of questions from mr. Oz now of
course as we know from the Oz effect
which is a video that we've already done
we've already covered that story mr. Oz
is the father of Superman now of course
that's been confirmed both in the story
as well as in the aftermath so it's not
like it was a red herring
that's definitively the case but because
of the fact that this takes place before
the Oz effects story meaning that mr. Oz
is still operating in his fortress as
still as Tim Drake being held captive
this goes back to his early days one of
the things to keep in mind is the origin
story of Tim Drake follows the death of
Jason Todd and the reason why was
because when it came to Robin in DC
Comics of course as we know Dick Grayson
was introduced to the Batman landscape
for the sake of boosting sales and it
did that almost overnight I mean it was
crazy how huge it was and Dick Grayson
remained Robin for almost 40 years
wasn't until shortly before crisis on
Infinite Earths but he became Nightwing
he sort of stepped in and became his own
hero so on and so forth now the idea
behind this was that following it at
Grace and he basically had the
introduction of Jason Todd now in the
pre-crisis landscape Jason Todd was
hated by most all the fans because his
origin story was basically copypasta it
was an exact duplicate of Dick Grayson
story and fans argument was if you're
gonna give us a new character don't copy
the origin story of a previous character
make him somebody interesting and so
after crisis on Infinite Earths DC
basically reworked the origin story of
Jason but he still wasn't wildly popular
because the water hasn't already been
tainted to a degree so they ended up
killing him off and in response to this
Batman became a lot darker
became a lot more ruthless in terms of
how he conducted himself the issue is a
DC was kind of in this weird scenario in
terms of the fact that there were a huge
percentage of Dick Grayson fans that
loved the idea of him being Nightwing of
him being his own superhero but Robin
was kind of part and parcel to the
Batman mythos and so the introduction of
Tim Drake came by way of the fact that
Tim just figured out that Robin was Dick
Grayson and Bruce Wayne was Batman and
that was it it was really
in terms of like deductive logic the
idea was a DC was using this as a way to
segue Tim Drake into the role of Robin
Sybil because of the fact that with Dick
Grayson established his knight wink DC
wasn't gonna change that so they kept at
Grayson as Nightwing even though Tim
Drake went to him and said look
Batman's more ruthless than he's ever
been he needs a Robin you have to go
back where Dick Grayson turned him down
Dick Grayson introduced Tim Drake to
Batman Batman took Tim Drake on his
Robin and he played that role for quite
some time until he moved on to his own
superhero to become Red Robin so again
it's kind of a cool little origin that
goes on there and a lot of that's
covered here in the first little bit the
problem with this is that again it's
really more of just sort of mr. Oz
picking up the pieces kind of figuring
out what's going on because remember
because mr. Oz is jor-el the father of
Superman who was yanked from the
destruction of Krypton by dr. Manhattan
and then thrown on earth what this means
is that in a lot of ways jor-el has
catching up to do he doesn't really know
what was going on on earth doesn't know
a lot about the history of the
characters and so as just as much about
learning about the past as it is him
taking Tim Drake for some ambiguous
reason that was never fully explained
now of course Tim Drake tries to
engineer his escape tries to get away
mr. Oz immediately overpowers him and
that's really the end of that this of
course leads directly into the odds
effect with regards to what happens
following this in mr. Oz but in the
middle of all that we also end up having
this information being brought to us
that Batman has effectively shown up to
rescue Tim Drake but the funny thing
about this is that where Tim is
initially happy to see Batman
Lesly enough having these doors more or
less being let down unlocked one is up
happening here is doomsday suddenly
arrives now the reason why this is so
intriguing is because in the middle of
all this Batman pulls out guns and as we
know that man has a no gun policy very
rarely does he ever use guns but this
version of Batman basically says look I
took the gun that killed my parents and
I repurposed it and I'm using it now and
this immediately sets off the Tim Drake
this is not Bruce Wayne and that's when
Batman takes off his mask it says no I'm
not Bruce Wayne I'm Tim Drake from
tomorrow from the future this is really
really cool because on the surface this
offers the ability for DC to go into
this really copypasta formulaic method
when it comes to time-travel and the
reason why I say that is because usually
when it comes to time-travel stories
time travel is invoked whenever a writer
puts themselves in a corner that they
can't get out of what you're gonna
notice here is that tinium doesn't do
that instead he takes the standard on
time-travel in comics and flips it on
its head but from there this whole
encounter with do
one of the things that's immediately
established is this future version of
Tim can easily hold his own between his
ingenuity his fighting training he's
able to kind of work his way around
doomsday but notice this is one of the
cool things here we start seeing skill
sets that Tim Drake doesn't normally
have and the reason why I say that is
because for me Tim Drake was never
really on par with like Damian Wayne or
Jason Todd or like Dick Grayson when it
came to fighting he comments on that in
this comic it says look I was never on
their level when it came to like
physical combat but I was smarter than
all of them and so because of that you
know where I'm not able to fight on the
same way they are I do know how to work
around their fighting styles and still
find ways to defeat them and this is
really kind of playing into the nature
of Tim tim has always been one of the
smartest members of the bat family even
if he's not the best fighter he's
certainly been like right up there when
it comes to being some of the smartest
guys the other thing about this is that
you know this future version of Tim
starts spouting off talking about how
things are gonna start crashing down but
one of the other things is established
here is the nature of time itself and
this is why I say Tinian really kind of
plays it pretty strict when it comes to
the use of time travel now in DC time
travel is in a lot of ways more strict
than it is with Marvel and a lot of
that's because of the aftermath the
ramifications of the use of time travel
because of the fact that the multiverse
exists out there you don't really see DC
offer this explanation that the
multiverse exists because something
different happened in the modern day and
because of that action in the modern day
it's spawned a different universe
instead it's just those universes are
out there those alternate realities are
there but they're not really part and
parcel they're not really rooted to some
action in the main DC universe so time
travel is basically one of those
scenarios where a person goes back in
time and it's really more of an
explanation it's really more of an
offering in terms of here's the future
that exists out there now it's up to you
to try to find a way to change it the
other half of this is that future Tim
Drake kind of goes on this explanation
of everything that'll happen later on
down the line not every single thing but
in terms of how it relates to Tim Drake
because when the present-day Tim asked
the question what could have possibly
gone so bad future Tim basically says
look a time will come when the bat
family will be betrayed and it will come
at the hands of that woman but when that
time comes when Bruce Wayne effectively
leaves the role of Batman then the first
person to take up the mantle is gonna be
Dick Grayson but dick Grayson's gonna do
what he always does Dick Grayson was
never destined to be Bruce Wayne because
Dick Grayson doesn't view
man the same way that Bruce Wayne does
Dick Grayson will play Batman for a
while then he'll move on Red Hood will
pick up the roll for a while he'll
engage in a fight with some mystical
ninjas
he'll basically end up losing a leg and
he'll lose an eye he'll basically step
down from the mantle because of that and
he'll losses we'll live kind of just
becoming a homeless derelict that exists
out there somewhere
following that Damian Wayne will take up
the role of Batman and he'll almost
destroy the city of Gotham in the
process because of how hardcore and
ruthless he is and so because everyone
failed after he Bruce left the mantle of
Batman it falls on the shoulders of Tim
Drake and Tim Drake just really kind of
does the best he can't but the world's
falling apart around him you know he
really kind of lashes out and says if
there were 80 other option I wouldn't be
here in the first place but I'm here
because I have to be I'm here because
the future that I live in is horrible
and I'm trying to find a way to stop it
from being that way and so again this is
really more of him dealing with the
present-day version of Tim because
remember one of the big plot points when
it came to Tim himself was that he never
really wanted to be Batman he wanted to
go off and be his own superhero he never
saw himself taking up the mantle but
making their escape and getting out of
the prison of mr. Oz and back to Gotham
City proper in the modern day one of the
things that ends up happening here is
that future Tim says look you know my
mission is done I've got you back here
you need to go you need to go talk to
spoiler but you also need to go talk to
a guy named Connor Kent now this is huge
this is massive because people who are
fans of DC and have been reading for a
long time know who Conner Kent is
following the death of Superman there
were four new Superman who rose up there
was the metropolis kid there was John
Henry irons also known as steel there
was the Eradicator and there was cyborg
the only one we need to worry about is
Conner Kent Conner Kent is basically
this kind of clone combining the genes
of Lex Luthor as well as Superman kind
of making him just like this perfect
amalgamation of the tube but the whole
idea behind this is that following the
death of Superman
Conner can't sort of went through this
huge landscape of all these different
roles that were played over the course
of his character but it was really more
of a bit of soul-searching once he
learned about his origin when Superman
actually returned he kind of went to
this existential crisis where he was
trying to figure out his place in the
whole world when DC rebirth kicked off
we'd see neither hide nor hair of Conner
Kent and a lot of people who were huge
fans of him kept wondering where he was
one of the things here is that Tim Drake
does not know who Conner Kent is now
remember this all feeds into the idea
that
Manhattan wiped ten years from the minds
of everyone and so presumably for Tim
Drake this includes all knowledge of
Conner Kent so what this means is that
Connors out there we've seen in
reference before Connor can't exist in
DC rebirth because of the fact that Tim
and Connor do have a history together
for future Tim Drake the question is why
don't you know who Connor kid is and
that's the huge question that goes on
here because what seems to be going on
is because with future Tim existing you
know some twenty however many years into
the future the idea seems to be that
things played out in this form that you
basically had dr. Manhattan who showed
up he wiped ten years from everybody's
memory and then all the events
transpired in DC rebirth Doomsday Clock
happen and then presumably in Doomsday
Clock dr. Manhattan restored
everybody's memories so that future Tim
Drake remembers Connor can't or he you
know ran into Connor can't but then
again this also plays into the idea that
with this version of Tim Drake his
timeline is different and so it may be
that in the future his said that he
comes from dr. Manhattan never wiped the
minds of everybody for ten years a lot
of those questions aren't really
answered here we're just kind of left to
this bit of information but because of
the fact that he's is you know
explicitly from the future of this
universe you know my original theory on
Doomsday Clock in Manhattan fixing
everything really seems to hold up and
the reason for that is because in order
to test the waters here future Tim cuts
his younger self and when he does future
Tim ends up with a scar on his arm that
happens immediately and so his
recollection is I can fix this timeline
I can make it so that my future never
happens and it's really really
interesting because it kind of plays on
those stereotypical time-based concepts
in the sense that somebody comes back
from the pet from the future and they
want to save the future or something
along those lines but the way this
transpires is wildly intriguing because
with with present-day Tim being knocked
out feature Tim goes on this crusade
with the intention of taking out that
woman since she will be the first step
leading to his own future where he goes
on the hunt for that woman his this
present-day self you know present-day
Tim I just kind of knocked out by my way
of an electric shock and then somebody
presumably takes him to the hospital or
at least calls an ambulance but with his
beacon effectively activating Bruce
Wayne's alerted by Alfred and
immediately comes to the realization
that Tim Drake is in Gotham City he
races to the hospital grabs Tim you know
kind of holds him for a second you know
and then this basically breaks down into
the whole scenario of what in the world
is going on here and so because it's the
return of present-day Tim of course most
people are gathered the only person you
don't really see here is spoiler but
present-day tim basically
look there's a future version of myself
running around here and his goal is to
take out Batwoman now this is where I
say Tynan begins to break away from a
lot of the traditional constructs when
it comes to time-traveling because
traditionally speaking and really a lot
of comics in general do use time travel
one of the things you'll see is that you
know future Tim is masquerading as
present-day Tim and he's gonna betray
everybody and trick everyone that's not
what happens and it's actually a great
reprieve because that would be so cliche
and that's what I love about tin Ian's
writing he doesn't really go for cliche
things instead you have present-day Tim
who just shows up at a hospital and
Bruce Wayne rescues him and then he
comes back and he warns everybody about
what's going on but the other thing
about this and the reason why this is
cool is because it's basically James
Tinian telling us
yeah present day you know Tim Drake is
there and it won't matter this is
designed to show how capable future Tim
Drake becomes but we're battlements kind
of kept in this sort of stasis box for
her own protection present-day Tim Drake
kind of spills the beans on everything
he's been told so far about the future
version of himself as well as everything
he observed and one of the things that
he points out here is look this future
version of myself
was able to take on doomsday by himself
if any of you fight him one-on-one he
will kill you and he will not hesitate
to do so because he genuinely believes
that he's saving his future and so what
we end up doing is we basically have
Bruce Wayne and present-day Tim asking
the question if this future version of
Tim is hunting around and he's trying to
find that woman
he still has these subconscious
processes that he's trying to satisfy
these urges that he needs to take care
of and the question is where would be
the first place he would go well the
answer is he would go to the first place
that brings some comfort the place that
he calls home Wayne Manor and so
initially he comes across you know
Alfred Pennyworth now again this really
hits home to do lure of a lot of things
that go on in the future the idea that
maybe Alfred died somewhere along the
line and Tim Drake hasn't seen him for
quite some time but it is an interesting
question here because Tim Drake asks if
I had to do something terrible in order
to save my future do you think I should
do it if that woman has to die in order
to keep the rest of the bat family
together and to save the future then she
has to not classic utilitarianism if
that woman is truly the first domino
they get set in motion that knocks all
these are the dominoes down and it leads
to this dark future that Tim Drake comes
from then it's logical that she should
have to die but that's assuming a linear
time line that's assuming that if she
dies everything will be okay but that's
the nature of Todd wheeler
about that from flashpoint you know we
learned from flashpoint Barry Allen went
into the past saved his mom's life that
spawned this worse universe and the one
that he lived in it made sense that she
had to die that the mother of Barry
Allen had to die in order for the
regular universe to be preserved and
that's the nature of what goes on here
is that when you have Tim Drake
basically met with the arrival of Damian
Wayne a Red Hood of Dick Grayson and ace
the bat-hound to face off against Tim
Drake one of the things he says is in
this present day right now I don't see
myself on par with you guys but I fought
image Holograms of you guys I basically
learned all your strengths and all your
weaknesses and so it's important that
you understand your place in the bigger
picture I care about you but you're
about to receive one of the most
spectacular ass whippings in the history
of your life and that's exactly what
happens this fight breaks out in the
entirety of Wayne Manor you know you end
up having Alfred Pennyworth come running
downstairs man guys future Tim Drake is
here and he just wrecked Red Hood and
Damian Wayne and Dick Grayson so like
you guys need to be involved and that's
so cool is because what this basically
highlights is the idea the future Tim
Drake is a one-man army when this bad
family bands together for the intention
of trying to take on Tim Drake they just
were prepared that's exactly what
happens they were unaware of what was
gonna happen not only that Tim Drake
basically says look you guys think you
have a chance but it's not just my
fighting prowess it's not just my
intellect that's been improved over the
years
I can also tap into the system that
Batman's been working on and where
Batman is beginning the early processes
of it in my future it's already
completed not only that I've mastered it
I've controlled it and I use it through
my suit and when the question is asked
what it is they're talking about Bruce
Wayne reveals the existence of brother I
now brother is a huge deal when it comes
to DC because brother eyes one of the
coolest things out there now brother I
was basically Batman's satellite system
that was designed to monitor all
metahumans whether they were superheroes
are villains or just you know
independent rogues that existed out
there but the idea with brother AI is
Batman used it to monitor everything
that was going on on earth but with
regards to the - this whole thing one of
the things to keep in mind here is that
we've seen brother I compromised you
know for example during the events of
countdown to Infinite Crisis one of the
things we saw was the villain Maxwell
Lord who had taken control of brother AI
but
member because of the fact that dr.
Manhattan wiped ten years from
everybody's mind while Batman had
created brother I and brother I are
being compromised on the surface we
would see him repeating the same mistake
before but Batman doesn't know he's
doing that because those memories have
been wiped from his mind by document
happening but regardless of how it turns
out the immediate effects of Tim Drake
you know from the future being in the
modern day is felt when he basically has
time kind of yanking against him and
that's the cool thing about this is
because we're Marvel kind of experiment
with the idea that time is not a fixed
construct times a living organism one of
the cool things about this is that this
hit of the idea the time constantly
fights back that there are fixed points
hurdles we can't knock them over you
can't move them around they're stuck
there you cannot actually change them
for example Batman always exists
Superman always exists these things are
absolute constructs somewhere along the
line Batwoman will do something and
it'll basically start bringing down the
entire bat family what that thing is we
don't know but it's cool because we're
you know Tim Drake is trying to kind of
stop this future from happening but
what's basically taking place are two
things at the same time one time is
trying to yank him back to the future
it's trying to stop him from changing
the past at the same time he's trying to
change things that cannot be changed but
notice this him taking out Batman feeds
on the weakness of Batman you know that
being Batman is a curse you know that
being Batman has a terrible scenario you
don't want anybody else to be Batman not
because you want to keep the title to
yourself but because you know what it
costs you feeding on that weakness of
Bruce for a brief amount of time allows
Tim direct to get the upper hand
and knock him out it's feeding on the
trust of Bruce from there you know he
basically compromises the entirety of
brother I'd and controls it through his
own suit travels over you know basically
has all these drones seek out bat woman
try to take her out it's a cool scenario
and it's a cool thing because there's
this massive conversation that happens
between present day Tim and future Tim
and it's really interesting because it's
basically featured Tim saying look I'm
making your life better that woman is
the one that sets this chain of events
in motion that makes my future just let
me take her out when this is done get
back together with spoiler go and have
your life go live and that's the cool
thing about this is because it shines
future Tim Drake in a new light we could
look at him as just kind of like some
archetypical villain Riley he's going
back into the past and he wants to take
our bat woman that's kind of what we
would expect from this but it shines it
in a new light because in his mind he's
saving the bat family him giving words
of advice to Tim Drake and saying go
live your life
it's amazing the
he's genuinely trying to do the right
thing he genuinely believes he's a good
guy here now of course this leads
directly into the arrival of you know
all the other drones and the rest of the
bat family so on a so forth you know
pursuing future Tim Drake and they kind
of fight you know where they can they
take things out here and there but it is
cool because in the final moments of
this battle when future Tim realizes
there's no way for him to succeed that
this is a fixed construct in the end
it's not about stopping this event it's
about the choices that you make and
that's why I say business basically
designed to sort of explain who don't
quote time travel in DC Comics there are
fixed things that always happen these
are absolute constructs things never
change the defining factor of what it is
that led to present-day tim becoming
future tim were the choices that he made
along the way and that's the
significance of the song that's why it
all matters so much is because there's
no way to stop that woman from making
her decision there's no way to stop her
from betraying the bat family what
defines future Tim is how he reacted to
it and that's the last piece of advice
that he gives to his present-day self I
finally realized what's going on
Batwoman will betray the bat family but
when that happens make the right calls
make the right decisions do not become
me and so the result is that he's
basically yanked back to his future and
we're just kind of left with Tim Drake
trying to figure out what the next step
should be and how to deal with the idea
that that woman is gonna betray the bad
families that she's gonna do something
this guy's set in motion the future of
himself some 20 years later on down the
line but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like definitely one of my favorite
stories so far
I absolutely love this is pretty amazing
well that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]